hello and welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend
started out as a bit of a lark didn't it
sona when we first started doing this
remember we just were screwing around
with
two microphones yeah and i don't even
think mr gourley were you
even part of the project i think i did
like no i don't think you were driving
i was a hitchhiker and you picked me up
on like the way to the third episode or
something
exactly yeah yeah i picked you up and uh
yes
you tried to murder me yeah but um i got
the knife away from you and then you
said oh i also produce podcasts yeah i
murder people that pick me up on the
road
i picked up a hitchhiker once who really
uh in hawaii
we were in maui who's we me erica brown
and ashley olivia used to also work on
the show yeah
and i was like we should pick him up
it's hawaii and it's fun and i
and eric was like uh he's a stranger and
i said once we pick him up he'll
probably be
fine and he wasn't so okay
uh i'm surprised because erica brown
worked for has worked for our show for
many years continues to work for us and
lovely and i had uh lunch with her today
by the way she's fantastic
she's the best very sensible smart and
sensible if erica brown said no no don't
pick up this person this person seems
sketch
right i wouldn't do it you ignored erica
brown which was your first mistake yes
you picked up this person described him
so he was like just this regular guy
and i thought yes it's the person she
married how tactical this is
this is a cute meat that's what it's
called okay thank you me cute
me cute or cute meanest boss not a cute
medium well cute okay
i like to quickly add like i've heard it
both ways which isn't true
yeah you do a meat cute to meet
someone's cute meat
okay it is cute like genitals oh it
could be i'm not saying
all right i'm sorry what a horrible
euphemism for genitals
i like your cute you said it cute meat
yep it was a
me cute to meet cutes
what no it was no no it was a meat cute
to see cute meat yeah and then i was i
i've translated cutes as like genitals
like it's a meat
it's a it's a meat cake that's what i
meant okay yeah thank you
yeah you need to get on the same page as
being quarterly
i understand what you guys are talking
about at all i've never been more
disconnected
in a conversation in my in my life and
this is a podcast
you're on your own podcast i'm on my own
podcast which apparently has a massive
audience
and i talk for a living and in my
personal
and private life and and public life
i've never had a conversation
where i feel this loss yeah i don't know
what you're talking about tell us what
this guy
looked like okay so he was like this
just this normal white guy
he was on the side of the road in hawaii
when we picked him up i was like i'm
sure we'll get to know him and it'll be
fun and we'll become
friends we find out he's squatting in a
house
in maui with his like partner and their
kids
he uh smokes a lot of meth a lot of meth
goes to raves a lot does a lot of
ecstasy
and every time he reached into his bag
to get something we were like he's going
to pull out a machete
and he's going to kill you know all of
us you know what hard to use a machete
in an enclosed space
you need to if there's an arc to that
weapon yeah i would yeah i wouldn't
worry if i was in a car with someone in
the
machete i'd say do your best all they're
going to do is cut up
yeah this is a rental go for it it's got
a low roof
you're not going to be able to get the
full extension go for it let's see and
then
yeah as he tried to get at me but kept
hitting the seat belt
and the window i'd just be laughing like
keep trying [ __ ] her
yeah and dragonize the guy with the
machete yeah come on
he'd hit the head rest and go like oh
hijacker hit the head wrench
and that'd be like try it again come on
buddy boy
put your back into it i'd really taunt
him um so
huh wow that was a stupid idea so how
did you get rid of old meth head jones
we drove
it we i was like maybe he won't be in
the car long and then an
hour and a half later what do you mean
drop him off at his stop
oh so you took him to his stop yes did
you ever think of
pulling over to the side of the road and
saying can you get out i'm worried about
our left rear tire
and then peel out do you think about
doing that no i never did that that's
what i would have done
i've done that to my wife like i'm
worried about that tire really yeah now
screech and then i get home first and we
watch what i want to watch
oh um you never picked up a hitchhiker
no
it's a good idea not to yeah yeah i was
never tempted to pick up a hitchhiker
yeah but what were we talking about
before this
meeting people's cute meat oh great i'm
glad you're reminding me and me
cute so that you could oh i get why he's
confused
what well cause i i said it's a meat
cute and then
it was to meet cute what's cute that's
what we're saying
genitals that was what we were saying
but cutes aren't
called gen i know but i was thinking
genitals genitals are called cute meats
that's what i thought see matt i messed
up that that's what i
thought i meant that's what i thought we
know sona
we know yeah you don't have to keep
yelling i messed up it's a given you
know it's like a porpoise shouting
i'm all wet we know you live in the sea
you know
it's not necessary it's an octopus going
on lots of arms
we know it's a camel i could use a drink
of water
we know camel we get it it's a bird
saying
hi i have the ability to fly we know
bird
it goes without saying it's soup going i
tell you i'm pretty hot
right out of the microwave we know soup
that's what you are
and you're like i've messed up we know
persona
the point is it's all good
it's all good and you got to see my
range of voices there
from a camel to a hot bowl of soup